as a european citizen freedom of
movement means that you have the right
to live and work in another eu country
but what happens to your social security
rights for example your health care
maternity or paternity rights
unemployment benefits or your pension eu
laws exist
to make sure you don't lose out but do
you know where to find information on
this
and should the eu do more to strengthen
social policies what action should it
take to better protect you
what about income tax europeans living
and working in another eu country than
their own
are subject to agreements at national
level this means that you could be hit
by double taxation
and what about public services are they
accessible to everyone
some services are opening up to the
private sector how can we guarantee
their continuity
and quality are there services that
should not be provided by the private
sector
what should the eu do if you've got
something to say
we want to hear it join the great social
rights online debate between 30th
september and 2nd of october
and share your views with eu politicians
and your european neighbours
it really could help shape what happens
next